they're dying in their beds here and the
numbers continue to rise kovat 19 is
ravaging Brazil
this is one of the worst-hit
neighborhoods in the Amazon rainforest
city of Manaus many people have died
many are infected in this single Street
well they think they are there's no
testing The Undertaker's are used to
this now they've been collecting the
dead for weeks this is a porpoise
service nobody here can afford a proper
funeral Manaus is a remote city but even
the vastness of the Amazon did nothing
to protect its people the virus swept
through here it still is well you don't
know with a lot of these things as to
win it actually a person has died from
Cove it or not in the current climate
because everyone has to assume they are
people here obviously extremely upset
it's a friend it's lots of them family
as well that's all it's been happening
non-stop and it's going to continue I'm
sure an interesting point is you're
actually in the town but this disease is
spreading into the Amazon forest and
that's what's concerning the authorities
fear that they can't get help to those
people in very very distant communities
neighbors friends and family watch on as
Afonso de Souza's body is taken away
another victim of another family another
community hit by this pandemic
there are no funeral cortege is for
these people no hearses minivans take
the bodies into the covert cemetery
the rainforest weather is staggering
getting the bodies to the burial site is
a mission in itself
if there is a backlog and there usually
is the coffins are offloaded into
refrigerated trucks the funeral
directors have more work elsewhere
outside family members not allowed in
wait at the gate free are allowed into
the cemetery if it's a covert death
we only saw groups of three
we didn't expect this the kovat part of
the cemetery is exceptionally grim grave
diggers in hazmat suits don't stop
digging new graves full more being dug
under a canopy family members wait for
their turn cemetery staff paint the
names of the dead on simple crosses the
latest victims are loaded onto a trailer
the families then follow a morbid
heartbreaking procession to a mass grave
this is their last chance to say goodbye
to family members who often died in
isolation and away from their loved ones
but there is respect even in the mud
what's the digger the driver doesn't
dump the earth it's placed and gently
eased over the coffins Cove it respects
nobody but the digger driver does
Fernanda Fernandez came to say goodbye
to her husband she's had kovat but
survived he did not make a travel also
so HKD there's a pharmacy fermented well
okay no fighter do mundo that are
familiar to our station is nice
you messed up estimate yeah yeah former
convoy only few me
[Applause]
oceanographers busy morning
[Music]
the deaths the infection race in Brazil
are staggering the government wants the
country to open up but it feels too
early if not reached the peak yet there
could be much worse to come
Girardi Sky News in the Amazon